>> OMA: Hi, my name is Oma, I'm an engineer
on the Android product. And today I want to
tell about an exciting key feature about platform.
Every application on an Android system is
able to create background services. We can
perform background test on your behalf while
you're busy doing something entirely different.
I’m in the application right here that I
want to show you and then demonstrate this
feature. This application lets you manage
a list of bodies from their website flicker.
And when I click on the body, I can see all
these photos from the website. Now, I really
like these photos and I don’t want to check
every hour or everybody if there's a new photo
available. So, the application is smart enough
to start a background service. And while I'm
using, for instance, the web browser and doing
other task, the application will keep checking
the account in the background and will send
you a notification as soon as a new a photo
is available. So here, I just got a notification
about a new photo. I just pull the status
bar, and when I click on the notification,
I get right back to the photos and I can see
the new photo for this body available in the
application.